غير بعيد عن العاصمه الاوكرانيه كليب وفي
شوارع ضواحيها المدمره قبل انطلاق سفيره
الانذار يتوقع جنود الدفاع الجوي من اجل
اسقاط الصواريخ القادمه من الحدود الروسيه
ولقنص الطائرات المسيئه من هنا يمكننا
تتبع مسار الصواريخ التي تطلق من البحر
لدينا زاويه رؤيه جيده تسمح لنا باسقاط
الصواريخ تصل المعلومات سريه للوحده بوجود
غارات على كيف قبل اطلاق سافرت الانذار
لدينا العديد من المواقع السريه التي تكشف
لنا عن اي شيء يحلق من عند العدو وحتى
وجهته وباي سرعه وتوجد مسافه امنه بين
الجنود وانا على تواصل المستمر معهم
يتلقون اوامري وتعليماتي اولا باول
الى بطل كلو كيف تتحدث عنه لانه قبل اسبوع
استطاع اسقاط طائره درون من نوع شاهد
ايرانيه الصنع
اشهر انظمه الدفاع وتعملوا بتكنولوجيا
تعقب عاليه الدقه تكشف وتدمر الهدف لكن
هنا الجندي هو من يقوم بكل شيء وبنجاعه
طائره باقدار التركيه وصواريخ الاربيجي
وايلا الصوفياتيه كلها اسلحه يقولها هؤلاء
انها غيرت كثيرا من معطيات الحرب الجاريه
لكنهم ينتظرون وصول منظومه الدفاع ارض جو
باتريوت الامريكيه